so before I went on vacation I received
an email that I wanted to respond to but
that I didn't have a chance I ran out of
time so I thought there's no reason why
I can't go back and respond to it now so
that's what I'm going to do alright
here's what it says Matt you are
constantly giving God credit for good
things that happen
but I noticed that you never blame him
for all the evil in the world if your
God exists and he is good as you claim
how do you explain a world filled with
rape murder torture terrorism sex
trafficking and so many other evils it's
clear to me that there is no evidence
for any kind of God there especially is
no evidence for a good God all right
so this is the classic why do bad things
happen to good people
objection and I think it's a good and
important and complex question and it's
one that Christians I've been talking
about and debating and writing about for
centuries since the beginning
I also think it's kind of a weak
argument against the existence of God
and so it's a it's a good question to
talk about I don't think it's a great
argument against you know in the on for
the atheists I don't think it's a good
argument in the atheist corner I also
think that my friend here in the email
didn't even use the best version of his
own argument he made the same oversight
that a lot of atheists surprisingly make
when it comes to this objection which is
they use the weakest version of it so
let's unpack it and we'll start with
this there are two forms of bad things
that might happen to a person just
broadly speaking right there are two
categories of bad things that happen in
the world there's the kind of bad thing
that the email described which is rape
murder and so on things that are the
result in other words of human choices
if you're the victim of rape or murder
that is the result of the choice of not
yourself but somebody else the person
who is victimizing you then there are
the bad things that may happen to you as
a result of your own choices and then
there are the bad things that happen to
you as the result of a combination of
your own choices and the choices of
other people so take for example a man
who commits a crime goes to jail and
then is murdered in jail well the fact
that he was murdered is the result of
the choice of the person who murdered
him but the fact that he was in jail to
be murdered was the result of his own
choice and I think a lot of bad things
are kind of explained that way where
there's a combination of there's a kind
of there's a whole storm of bad choices
blowing this way and that from all
different directions
and it results in all kinds of bad
things the other category the one that
this atheist didn't even mention but
which I think presents a greater
challenge to believers that is the
category of bad things that happen
seemingly apart from anyone's choice at
all
so diseases okay or well of course there
and there are diseases that are the
result of choices that we make but there
are many many many tragic millions of
tragic examples of people being killed
by horrible diseases completely apart
from any choice at all that they made it
just happened to them they were just
victims of it and that's all take the
most tragic example of all of course
would be a child who dies of cancer how
could God create a world where a
five-year-old obviously through no fault
of his own dies of leukemia or where
anyone dies of leukemia or a world where
anyone could die of any kind of horrible
agonizing disease at all
now I'm going to try my best to answer
both of these
I should warn at the beginning that I am
NOT a theologian and the answer that I
give is just my own answer now it's an
answer that I hope is grounded in
Christian teaching and in Scripture but
my point is if it's a bad answer or
incomplete or poorly conveyed then blame
me for it
okay don't blame Christianity that's
that would be my fault
now to understand these things we have
to go back to the Christian doctrine of
the fall
and it seems like there are a lot of
atheists and secular people who just
simply don't understand this doctrine
and have made no attempt to understand
it and that's a problem because if
you're going to raise these kinds of
objections against Christianity then you
have to understand at least on some
level this doctrine because it all goes
back to this
now it's our belief as Christians that
God created originally human beings who
were in complete harmony with him with
each other with themselves with nature
with the world they were living in
paradise so when an atheist says well if
God is loving why did he create a utopia
why didn't he create a world filled with
nothing but love and happiness and
kindness and peace and prosperity well
the answer is he did create that world
that's exactly the kind of world he
created and he also created many other
forms of life on earth but the thing
that's separated and here's the rub okay
the thing that separated human life from
all other forms of life is that human
life was made in the image of God that's
what it says in Genesis and to be in His
image meant that these humans were not
merely slaves to instinct or to nature
they were given a will of their own a
free will the ability to choose between
one thing or another and that still is
the primary thing that separates us from
the animals is that we can make
judgments about what we ought to do and
what we ought not do animals cannot make
those kinds of judgments they can't
conceive of them they operate according
to instinct and if they make any kinds
of choices at all I'm going to run this
way or that way it is it these are
morally neutral choices and even those
choices in the end go back to instinct
we however are above that and so we can
assess this is right this is wrong I'm
gonna do the right thing or I'm gonna do
the wrong thing and that will that
incredible power
that God gave us is one of the primary
things that makes us creatures in His
image
now as long as these humans chose to
obey God and to remain in communion with
him they were happy and they were safe
and they were in paradise
God ruled over man and through man God
ruled over nature so we say that man had
dominion over nature dominion over the
animals
well of course God is really the one who
had dominion over nature and the animals
but he had dominion over nature over the
animals through man he ruled through man
and man was able to enjoy that he was
able to enjoy that Dominion so long as
he submitted to God's Authority now if
you're an atheist you don't let me just
step to the side of Herman if you're an
atheist you don't believe that any of
this happened I realized that I know but
the question that I was asked and that
atheists ask all the time is why would a
good God allow bad things I'm trying to
explain that I am NOT trying to explain
why God exists that's a completely
separate conversation I'm just trying to
explain how Christians can believe in a
good God who allows bad things and this
is one of the problems that we run into
when it comes to you know discussions
between atheists and theists is that
every conversation eventually goes back
to a about whether or not God exists and
of course inevitably it will come back
to that but if you're trying to
understand you know individual Christian
doctrines and if you're trying to
understand not just our belief in God
generally but our but I but our you know
but but the the the kind of our belief
in the the goodness of God and in the
nature the good loving nature of God if
you're trying to understand that then
you have to be able to
aside for a moment your objections about
the existence of God completely and
instead look at the individual doctrines
okay
so there was this harmony and then man
chose to rebel against God so before we
got there now we just got into the
rebellion but before we got to that
point everything makes sense in terms of
well this is what a loving God would do
right Garden of Eden paradise even from
an atheist perspective even though you
don't believe in God but I guess you
probably would say well yeah if there
was a God and he really was a good god
that's the kind of world he would have
made okay great
that's the kind of world he did make
according to Christians but there was
that that thing remember that power that
will that free will that choice that he
gave us
so man took that choice and he used it
to rebel against God and for the
purposes of this conversation it doesn't
really matter what what what exactly
that choice was the exact nature of that
choice for this conversation doesn't
matter the point is he was given at
every moment a choice between serving
himself and serving God and for a period
of time he chose to serve God he was
happy and then one day he chose himself
and then catastrophe struck and a whole
literal world of misery followed now the
objection to that is well why would
anyone choose that you're in paradise
you're in Utopia
I mean it's unreasonable to claim that
somebody could be in paradise and then
choose to destroy all of that well it is
in the end and unreasonable choice but
it is but is it unreasonable to believe
that that a that a person in paradise
would make that choice no it's not
unreasonable at all
I mean look even at your own life you
have made in your own life if you're
going to be honest about it
you have made smaller versions of that
exact same choice I'm sure there have
been points in your life when you know
you have been in a situation where there
is relative harmony and ease and
happiness and then you do something that
destroys it and later on you look back
on it with a little bit of maturity and
wisdom and hopefully with some
self-awareness and you say why did I do
that
it's crazy why I you know I had this
good thing why did I ruin it
or take a more extreme example of a very
common example of somebody who's in
basically a happy marriage a peaceful
marriage a marriage with harmony and
unity and then one day they go out and
have an affair and even the
pher itself there's that fleeting
physical pleasure that comes with the
affair but it's also caked in on both
sides and guilt and and secrecy and lies
in misery and all of that for this
fleeting pleasure and then in the end it
ends up destroying this good wonderful
thing that the adulterer had and that
person is going to look back on it later
and they're gonna say why did I do that
you know when they're divorced and
they're living alone in their
one-bedroom apartment and their spouse
hates them and their kids hate them
they're gonna look back on that
wonderful thing they had living in that
you know in that nice home with the
white picket fence and the kids and the
the nice family and the vacations and
now they're now they're just alone in
misery and they're gonna say I did I do
that I had everything so the point is
you know it's not that hard to
understand how a man in Paradise could
choose to destroy it because people have
continued making exactly that choice
over and over and over again and you
yourself have made it on some level at
various points in your life so man chose
to rebel and there was this break there
was this divorce you know use the
example of marriage for a reason because
that's the example that scripture uses
constantly in in describing man's
relationship to God the image of
marriage is used frequently and God
through the prophets in the Old
Testament is constantly accusing sinners
of being adulterous not because they're
literally committing adultery although
sometimes they are but but what he's
saying is that they are adulterers
because they are betraying him they're
betraying their relationship to him so
this image of marriage is used and so it
makes sense to say that at the fall
there was this split this divorce and
the unity the harmony was destroyed by
the free choice of man man had
paraded himself from God and in the
process he had lost in many respects his
dominion over nature
he became subject to nature he found
himself at nature's mercy because he had
stepped out of line he'd stepped out of
the process remember there was this
process there was God man nature God
ruled nature through man man had
dominion over nature while man
extricated himself from that process and
ended up literally in the wilderness and
now at the mercy of nature and so in
some sense he still has dominion over
nature but also Nature has dominion now
over him and this is where things like
disease and senility and human frailty
and all of that come into the picture
but then the next question is ok well so
it makes sense that the first human
beings were given this choice they made
the bad choice they suffered the
consequences well then why do we all
have to suffer the consequences and
there is an element of mystery there we
can't get around we can't escape it God
could have corrected the problem right
away he could have corrected it balanced
the account changed everything
during mankind's first generation but he
chose not to why did he make that choice
well I mean nobody can speak absolutely
to the motivations of God I think that's
a very dangerous thing to try to do I'm
not even going to attempt it but I will
say this we have to understand that a
change occurred not just to the
individual people involved at the time
personally but a change occurred to the
human species to the human race a change
occurred to our very nature there was a
change in the nature of man
these being the first humans our first
parents them stepping out
then stepping away from that harmony
with God well kind of logically by doing
that they took all of us out of harmony
again it's not that hard do
to understand when we look at on a
personal level we look at examples that
are all around us now maybe examples
that are on in our own lives think about
a
a father who chooses to be abusive you
know a father who chooses to be an
abusive tyrant
well when the father decides to be like
that a change occurs to the family
itself to the nature of the femme and
the consequences will be felt through
the generations a new course is set
or you know what but I think a better
example is let's go back to the divorce
yeah let's there was the divorce that um
when when man at the fall betrayed God
there was that divorce think about
divorces in you know actual personal
marriages
and let's say it's a divorce where one
person where a man decides to abandon
his family
um well in doing that he has broken the
family apart
without the direct consent of all the
other members of the family
and he has set the family on a new
course a bad course and it is a and he
is he has he has set off a series of
consequences that will be felt all
through down the line that will be felt
by his children and his children's
children and his children's children's
children even fifteen generations later
you can look at children that are that
are being born 15 generations later and
you could say correctly that they would
not be quite like this if not for the
choice that that man made 15 generations
ago
you know there is this where all we are
all connected right we're especially in
a family we're all we we are all
connected and the choices that we make
affect others and the choices that we
make as parents have effect on our
children and all down the line so it
makes sense that this horrible choice
that our first parents made would be
felt all down the line
so that's all kind of on the first
aspect of the question
that's my very brief and insufficient
explanation about how disease entered
the world and why we are suffering the
consequences of the fall today but let's
look at the second aspect of the
question what about all the bad things
that happen as a result of people
victimizing each other
this I think is easier to understand
especially in light of what we just
talked about and it's pretty simple I
think God gives us the power to choose
just as he gave Adam and Eve the power
to choose he also gives us the power to
choose and though they chose wrongly and
we inevitably suffer the consequences of
that wrong choice still we have the
power to choose rightly now you can't
help it if you were born to a broken
family divorced parents abusive father
whatever but you can help carrying that
on you can help it if you make the same
choice your likelihood of making the
same choice may be increased because
your parents were terrible but you don't
have to make the same choice you could
make a different choice
and if you end up in the same situation
you know if your parents were abusive
terrible and then you end up abusive and
terrible I think your parents deserve a
lot of the guilt and blame for that
because they set you on that course but
you also deserve 100% of the guilt and
blame because in the end you still made
a choice
why are we given a choice why does God
allow us to make bad choices
because choice and the potential for a
bad choice is necessary
for love to exist love is a choice
and if we really are going to love God
and love each other we have to choose it
if you don't choose love then love is
meaningless
if your wife doesn't choose to love you
then her love for you means nothing
if your life if your wife wants to leave
you and leave the marriage and your only
way to keep her with you is to lock her
in the basement then the fact that she
is still with you and in the marriage is
meaningless she's only there because she
has no other choice but to be there
if we have no choice but to love God
then we are just God's robots we are
God's puppets
we are not creatures made in His image
we are just puppets on a string and in
that case in a world without choice and
without meaningful chosen love then we
would have to look at all the misery and
all the suffering and say that it's all
part of some weird awful game or stage
player that God is putting on but that's
not the case God wants us to love he
created a world with love he created it
in love God is love himself and God
wants us to share in that love he wants
us to be virtuous to be holy to be good
to have joy but none of that can happen
without choice but choice the choice to
do something presupposes the option of
doing the opposite if you have the
choice to do X and X is good then you
must also have the choice to do Y even
if Y is bad if you had no choice but to
do X then you never had a choice and you
didn't choose to do X and therefore X is
meaningless
the fact that you're doing X means
nothing
um
and if God gives us the choice to do bad
or good but then every time we try to do
bad he just reaches out his hand and
blocks us from doing it every single
time then then then again we never
really had a choice
so
why does God allow
you know a man to set a building on fire
for the same reason he allows a man to
rush into a burning building and rescue
a child from it
if a man can't choose acts of cowardice
and evil and destruction that he cannot
choose acts of courage and
self-sacrifice and generosity
if we if we if we do not want a world
with the potential for evil then that
means we don't want a world with the
potential for good
and that's not to say that good is
dependent upon evil it's not to say that
this isn't dualism we're talking about
here I'm merely saying that the point of
life is to choose God and choose good
and and in such a point such a purpose
can't be achieved in a world where the
opposite choice is impossible
is a choice by its nature
and so what you could really say is God
could not have created a world where
there is love but no free will
because love is a certain thing love has
a nature
um
again God is love
love by its nature is an act of will
God's love is perfect because his will
is perfect which isn't to say that he
doesn't have a will but his will is
perfect
um but this idea that well why didn't
God choose a why didn't God make a world
where there's love and happiness and
harmony but there's no choice for
anything else and we're all just
automatic
well because that's nonsensical that's
kind of like the question of can God
make a you know create a boulder that's
so heavy he can't lift it
that's just a nonsensical question it
means nothing and to say well could
there be a world with love but no choice
and no will that's just nonsense it
means nothing
it's like saying can there be a world
with up and no down it's just it doesn't
it doesn't make any sense now there's
one other thing to remember and this is
really important of course as Christians
you know it's like we can't leave this
part out of it that the Christian belief
my own belief and if you're trying to
and the Christian believes you have to
also keep this in mind that God did not
abandon us to this fate yeah he created
a world that created a paradise man
chose to abandon that chose to serve
himself rather than God and that choice
has been repeated billions of times down
the generations by everybody and and
many horrible things happen as a result
and continue to happen
however God did not abandon us to that
he did he's not just sitting back and
saying oops he's not just sitting back
and saying well you know sorry about all
that guys you're out of luck and that's
why God sent his son that's why God sent
Christ's God himself came to earth
incarnate to redeem mankind to kind of
drag us out of the pit they talked about
the example of the you know of the
burning building and the man who rushes
in well God Himself was the man who
rushed into the building to save us and
so even though we live in a world now
where there is misery and misfortune and
pain and suffering and agony and all of
those things we are not abandoned to
that world we are not doomed to live in
it forever and this is not the whole
picture the whole story this is not the
whole point the full point the full
purpose will be realized in the next
life
but it is it is inevitable in the
meantime that choice is a is a part of
the story and that we have to continue
making the right choices we have to
continue choosing God so hopefully that
was a somewhat sufficient explanation
although if you're trying to find I
can't find it if you're really looking
for had the book somewhere if you're
really looking for a better explanation
as to you know if you want a better
answer to this question I'll hear this
pick up this book problem of pain by
seus louis it's it's you know it's
really short and thin here and he
addresses this same question and he
doesn't much better than I do and you
can read this whole book in like a
couple hours and so I recommend that you
do that as well thanks for watching
everybody
god speed